steam deck just got a big update and it
includes the ability to transfer
installed games and game files between
PCS and steam decks via a local network
the steam local Game Network transfers
as they are officially called will let a
user copy both installation and update
files from one PC to another or from a
PC to a steam deck so long as both
devices are connected to the same local
area network the feature will also let
each user decide with whom they would
prefer to transfer with no one only
devices logged onto the same account
devices owned by friends of the active
account or any steam user the official
steam blog post for the feature does
Supply a list of requirements in order
to make the local game transfers work
and that includes both devices must be
connected to steam and be able to find
each other on the local network both
steam accounts must allow file transfers
the account transferring files out must
be idle meaning no active downloads or
games running the game being transferred
needs to be released to the public and
playable by both steam users and lastly
the game being transferred must have the
latest installed update on the device
transferring the files out the new steam
deck update will also address multiple
bugs and new features a list which
includes the addition of streamable
games to the ready to play filter
support for the Sony dual settings Edge
controller including support for
remapping of the rear buttons and the
reduction of flashing in the background
when scrolling through the home screen
another major update that's out right
now is the finale to the Los Santos drug
wars in GTA Online titled the last dose
this update has players unraveling a
psychedelic conspiracy involving Dax and
the fooligans as they head down in
action-packed Rabbit Hole brimming with
familiar faces Hired Guns sabotage
kidnapping and more there are five new
missions in the last dose and players
can get started by accepting a phone
call from Dax or by visiting the freak
shop everyone who plays the first dose
and the last dose missions will get
double GTA dollars NRP through March
29th however if you're looking for
something a bit more family friendly
then check out the new additions to
Nintendo switch online slowly but surely
Nintendo continues to build out the
Retro games library for members of its
online service and today the company
added four more titles for subscribers
headlined by Kirby's Dreamland 2 on Game
Boy the other three games are Burger
Time Deluxe on Game Boy xevius on Ness
and side pocket on SNES it was only last
month when Nintendo introduced Game Boy
titles for switch online members with
standouts like Metroid 2 return of Samus
Legend of Zelda Link's Awakening DX and
Tetris Nintendo also brought Game Boy
advanced games into the fold so those
titles are for the premium switch online
plus expansion past members the Game Boy
library on Nintendo switch online now
stands at 11 titles with Nintendo
already confirming that four more are
coming soon including Pokemon Trading
Card Game The Legend of Zelda Oracle of
Ages and The Legend of Zelda Oracle of
Seasons let me know what game you play
most on your steam deck or your Nintendo
switch if you have either one of them
and I'll see you tomorrow
foreign